foreign
[Music]
results
um after being raped the night before
very surprised by them because I thought
I would fail them all and you know I did
I did get a D in Psychology because I
literally was in one of the exams I'd
written a suicide note rather than
actually
um rather than actually do the exam
[Music]
extraordinary lives from blood Bible I'm
seeing here today with Kate Alicia
um great to have you Kate
um would you mind just introducing
yourself
um yeah my name is Kate Alicia and I'm a
grooming gang Survivor and a qualified
mental health nurse so obviously the
topics that we're going to talk about
today are
um very very dark and upsetting and
um if anything's asked in a way that you
feel uncomfortable with or you'd like
rephrasing or anything like that please
just do let me know so for anyone
listening that might not be completely
clear what is a grooming gang
um so
um
while I was being
um abused I didn't really see them as a
gang they
um were some
um people on the street who um were
actually neighbors of mine
um and they but the the way they behaved
was in a gang-like fashion
um so they were an organized crime gang
already
um but they also engaged in
um the rape and exploitation of young
girls I understand and it what we're
here to talk about today is your very
unpleasant experiences with that gang
where did it start for you you know when
you say that there were they were an
organized
crime gang that we are neighbors did you
grow up in that kind of area did you
grow up in like a rough neighborhood and
that was natural or was it something you
moved into no so um I I grew up
um like elsewhere
um and not too far away really
um but I um
I moved out of home when I was 18.
um and
um I know that a lot of
um
the sort of typical what you would think
of a grooming gang victim would be
somebody who's come from a broken home
okay but
um
it actually they work on your
vulnerabilities and some some people may
have come from a difficult upbringing
but um my vulnerabilities were slightly
different to that so
um I was
um I moved out of home when I was 18
because
um my
um house was becoming quite crowded and
I was old enough to move out so it
wasn't really seen as a big issue
um so I left home and I moved to the
town where I was actually doing my a
levels which was in Telford
um and because I'd been there I was in
my second year of um college so it I've
been going to that town every day for
the last year and a half and it looked
like quite a nice place to live so I
moved
um I did end up moving to
um supported living for
um uh young tea like sort of teenagers
between the age of 18 and 25.
um
and because that was supported it's a
supported accommodation so it seemed
that also seemed to be
um the best place for somebody as young
as I was while I was still at college
um
and
um it just happened that the the
um road that I was living on that I
moved into
was
um dominated by a particular gang you've
heard of like gangs having sort of
postcode Wars and so the the street that
I moved into had a
um had a gang on it which I didn't I
didn't understand I didn't know anything
about
um I was I was only 18 and I only just
moved home so there was a lot that I
didn't didn't know about the world
um and so
um I was kind of very naive and sort of
blind to actually what was going on on
the street was the street itself when
you moved there did it feel like a
dangerous Street or did it feel like a
normal street in the middle of a town
um probably in hindsight you might have
seen groups of groups of people or
groups of men or young young people on
the street that actually were part of a
gang but you don't want to make that
assumption about everyone that you walk
past and it had a little park at the end
of it and it was only a short road and
it was the road that um we that I'd
walked through at lunch times to get my
lunch between college and the the Town
Center so it honestly looked like quite
a little Bright Street really with trees
on it and you know wouldn't even think
anything of it I don't think okay so at
the moment you're a normal student
living a normal life with accommodation
that's been sort of subsidized by the
colleges out right
by the government really I think the
council right yeah and so at what point
did you start to fraternize with people
that you would later realize were a gang
um so
um I actually I
um I was introduced to them by accident
because
um technically I was fairly
um
uh mature for my age really and I
wouldn't have hung out with them by
choice so I kind of fell into it by
accident
um and I think it was really through me
being a a kind or thinking of myself as
a kind person so um when I first moved
into the YMCA I wanted to make friends
with the the other young people in the
YMCA so I wasn't
um trying to make friends with every
neighbor but my next door neighbor that
was um in the flat next to mine
um and the neighbor
um who was on the other side of the
block of flats to mine I made friends
with them and they seemed quite
um okay you know they were same age as
me they were like the
um the same sort of people that I would
meet at college
and it started off it started off well
to be fair it um I um was friends with
one of the girls and then I was friends
friends with one of the boys um who's
William
um and um we had a little group of three
of us and then I had some friends that I
worked with
um in my part-time job and we all
started hanging out together and there
was about a group of five of us in total
um and all of that seemed absolutely
fine
and um it was William who had some other
friends
um and really I think that he was had
come from a broken home or something had
um
like he'd had more difficult upbringing
and he went to
um he went to a different College to us
and it was called necro and I didn't
realize at the time because I didn't
know anything about anything
but nakro is um for children who have is
a school for children who have
behavioral difficulties and may or may
not have a criminal record okay so
um he I mean he wasn't he wasn't evil he
was he was just vulnerable like we were
um and
I think we put too much responsibility
on boys
um to be more responsible of the girls
that they're with but really I just
think that he'd got mixed up in the gang
um probably because he was either taking
drugs or
um they'd coerced him into selling drugs
which I don't know I'm just speculating
um and
um he was friends with them and I don't
feel like it was necessarily by choice
um I think they were quite pushy with
him
um they used to use his flat for
um
using like dealing drugs or um what he
described as having sex with other girls
so he would you they would use his flat
because they couldn't use their own
house or that was their excuse
um and at the time it didn't sound right
but you know to begin with we didn't
know at all
um and then as sort of weeks go on of
being friends with someone they open up
a bit more
um and he starts telling us these things
are a bit odd
um
so that's um and he yeah that's how we
we and I ended up meeting these other
people on the street that were members
of gangs through William through being
friends with women you met the these
other members that lived on the street
through William and they were it sounds
like they were exploiting him when you
say they're using his Flats to do things
to deal drugs and things like that
um how did you begin to get more
involved with them um
um so there was
the I was having some difficulties with
them
um
uh William
um had uh so so he would sell his phone
um to Cash Converters to buy drugs
um or to I don't know maybe to live on
um for money to live on and then he
would buy his phone back at the end of
the month when he got paid again right
um and while he
um didn't have a mobile phone he was
giving my number out without permission
um as a way of getting in touch with him
so people started calling me to say
um is William there and I'd be like and
and then they would be calling me for
other reasons if I said William's not
there then they'd be trying to make
conversation with me over the phone
um and that's how they kind of got to
hear of me
um I don't know if William had talked to
them if he had I think it would have it
wouldn't have been in a malicious way it
would have been in in an innocent way so
perhaps he told them that he fancied me
or that he liked me in some way or I've
met this girl and I like her and they
because they were actually using him and
taking advantage of him they wanted to
have one up on him by getting his girl
or the girl that he fancied if that
makes sense
um so there was there was a male
dominant thing going on between him and
them at the time
and that's how I they ended up getting I
like they got my attention or
I got their attention Yeah you sort of
came into the radar ladies yeah yeah and
what was the if you don't mind me asking
and you happy to say what was the first
incident
so
mentioned that that Shamil was getting
I didn't know who Shamil was
um it was the first time anybody had
mentioned his name
um he wasn't on the street so I hadn't
even seen him around because he was in
prison
um and it was kind of word on the street
and
um they
um
are they sort of told me things about
him but I didn't really know who he was
um and then the first time
um he when he got when he did get out of
prison
um I was warned as well to avoid him so
I was absolutely to be honest terrified
I didn't know any criminals um and I
didn't really want to know any criminals
did you know what he was in prison for
um I'd heard lots of different things
but they were all violent so
um uh whether it was because he had
um broken somebody's jaw a stranger in
the street he said he'd beaten up
somebody said he'd been be not somebody
stranger in the street Broken their jaw
they'd be in a hospital and
um and then I heard that he'd broken
into somebody's house with a knife
obviously those things are completely
different so I don't know which one is
which
um whether either of them were true but
it sounded like it was something violent
anyway
um and when I um the first time I met
him I didn't realize this wishing me all
that everybody was talking about because
um William just stopped and started
talking to him
um and I um didn't think anything of it
at the time
um and it wasn't until he
um
knocks on my door
um that I actually met him properly
um so he knocked on my door William was
actually in
um I am at mine at the time and um when
I looked through the Spy hole it wasn't
him it was it was a a child
um so I didn't know I didn't know why a
child was knocking on my door so I just
answered it and when I answered the door
um I had a his he put his foot through
the door so we I couldn't then close it
the child or no Shamil the child
disappeared instantly so do you think
that was like a he'd done that so to
make sure you answered the door he made
a child okay yeah so he's quite
intimately yeah yeah so he tricked me
into answering the door by having a
child there
um and
um yeah that was obvious from the second
the foot was in the door and the child
was gone but there wasn't much I could
do about it apart from trying to push
him out
um so I started shouting to
um to William like help he's coming in
like someone trying to come in
um and William said is it Shamil and I I
said yes and he said let him in
um I think he probably said let him in
because he's scared of him yeah
um so I and because he'd instructed me
to let him in psychologically I just
stopped fighting and I let him in
because and you know like in that Split
Second you really wish that you hadn't
done that but then it just because you
only had a second to think about it was
just automatic so
um kind of maybe I was trusting William
I didn't know what was going to happen
maybe he knew what was going to happen
but I don't think he knew either so
um
also I don't know if I was winning the
fight
so I could feel as guilty as I like
about
that that Split Second that I let go of
the door but whether I was winning the
fight or not is is another question
because it was a foot in the door I
don't know what I would have done
um so
then he he came in he made some excuse
to William and then William left and the
thing is William is scared so he would
just do what you told him to
um and then William didn't come back and
um then he was alone with me in the flat
and it's kind of like
that moment that the door shut and
William had left and then Shamil was in
the flat with me was like the second
that you realized like in how much
danger you're actually in
um and
it was
um he was he was like literally circling
me
um and I was like I was a bit like a
scared rabbit basically so there was no
pretense of friendship it was just an
immediate sense of intimidation
um he was
um so he was saying things that appeared
like friendship but it was absolutely
terrifying so it was like I want you to
be my girlfriend this is a stranger that
I'd never met before and he's just come
out of prison for something violent
um and he was saying things like I will
I'll
buy you a car I'll buy you a house and I
was thinking how is the criminal gonna
buy me a house like I'm just terrified
about what's happening right now
um and
um he was
trying to hug me and he was trying to
kiss me and I was trying to push him off
me
um and but not in a not in a I was
trying not to be aggressive because I
didn't want him to be aggressive back to
me I was really terrified
um so that's kind of how it started and
then it just progressed from there
um he
like with trying to he was trying he was
undressing me and I couldn't stop him
from undressing me I was trying to say
like don't do that and um
stop and
um Can don't take my underwear off and I
was just trying to plead with him and
you know it sounds really pathetic but I
was so scared of course
um it doesn't sound pathetic at all it
sounds terrifying yeah sorry
um and
um
uh I managed to I don't know bargain
with him somehow to leave my underwear
on and she said please leave mine or I
don't like don't take anything else off
like just stop now at that
um and then he was because he was trying
to be pretend to be nice he was like
okay I'll leave your underwear on
um and then he um
put me down on the bed
um and got on top of me and then he was
um
uh undressing him a lot he must have
undressed himself first sorry but like
he was in his boxes and I even remember
the color
um which I won't share with you
um but um he
he was like
he was like like he agreed not to leave
my um underwear on so he just moved my
underwear out of the way and then
started to rape me and I knew what he
was doing but I just was too terrified
to like say anything else
um and I just had to like wait
underneath him until like he'd stopped
um and
um I don't like all the pleading that I
could possibly do and then when he
started to rape me I thought like I
haven't I can't actually
get out of this anymore like it's
happened now so
um I've just gotta wait till it's over
sorry no you don't need to apologize
awful situation and
after he'd finished did he leave the
house
um actually I think he just wanted to
put me I don't know why he's so I think
he was a bit of a psycho
um uh I can't even say that in a nice
way to be to be honest and I don't think
I should have to say it in a nice way of
course
um he I don't know what what was going
through his head but um he what he like
he was asking me afterwards like if I
found him attractive and he was asking
me if um
um what I thought of his body
um and I was very aware that I'd just
been raped and I was also still very
terrified of him so
um I but I also wasn't going to give him
the satisfaction of like
what he wanted to hear so I was like and
I was at the point where I didn't care
anymore as well so like he just raped me
so I actually hate you and um
I now kind of wish I was dead as well so
I don't really care what you do to me if
I tell you you're ugly and that I hate
you and so I said those things
um and he was like what
um but he didn't react I don't think he
knew how to react because I don't think
he knew what he was doing I don't think
he was all there psychologically
um and um and then he took me around to
William's house um Williams flat and
then he was saying in front of William
don't worry I only got her to give you a
give me a
um which isn't even remotely what
happened at all and I don't know why he
was saying that to him and
um and I was just the entire time I was
still shaking and not saying anything
because I thought um what am I gonna say
I just want really wanted to get rid of
him so I thought if I just wait until
he's gone then um then I can actually
process what's just happened
um and then he
he wanted to leave Williams flat so he
left and um then he wanted to kiss me
and I had to be like pin me against the
wall and I had to kiss him and then he
left
um and then finally I was on my own and
I thought oh God that was awful
um
and then William came back around and
then William was having a go at me
because he was like how could you give
him a blow job and I was just oh I was
just you know that didn't even have
that's not what happened just leave me
alone
um and
it's actually really messed up it's
really really messed up um and it's not
like what it might look like in the
movies and it's not a you know it
doesn't make any sense
um and you know one thing would lead to
to another and
um William pretended to leave my flat
after we'd gone back round
um and then I called my friend on the
phone who is my friend from school and I
told her that I'd just been raped
um and this was like at the first moment
I'd actually got to be myself
um and
um
she cried I cried and she cried on the
phone with me and it was like a really
upsetting moment
um
but then
I had to go because William hadn't
really left because he'd wanted to
actually spy on what I was going to say
to my friend and then he realized that
I'd been raped and then he was like
really apologetic about the way he just
behaved
um and he wanted to help me and he
wanted to um call his auntie and see
because he wanted a an adult woman to
talk to me to see what to do next and
they were all talking about going to the
police I was like oh my good you know I
couldn't hadn't had time yet to like
process anything so I was like still in
like this absolute shock and still
shaking
are you okay yeah I think so okay well
just let us know if you want a longer
break
okay
so
okay so I mean that's
that's quite a huge change in in your
experience living in that area
um and it's this individual Shamil was
clearly very dangerous and Disturbed was
he part of a wider group or was he kind
of a loan agent at that point
um he had he had some family members he
had a brother and he had a cousin and um
I sort of was aware of that but um I
hadn't you know I didn't understand the
way gangs were yeah um so I felt like he
was a loan agent but he clearly wasn't
um and I think
me not realizing that he was part of a
wider gang was even was you know was a
dangerous for me because the risk was a
lot higher than I anticipated
um so when I finally did speak to the
police a few
um days later so it wasn't I didn't
hadn't left it too long I just you know
needed to process and lots of people
were trying who I told I told lots of
people but the people I had told were
trying to convince me to speak to the
police yeah so um I went to the police
and um I spoke to them in absolute
um confidence because I so I I never
told anybody I didn't tell William I
didn't tell my friend my next door
neighbor who we were friends with I
didn't tell my family I because I was I
was really terrified of
what chamille might do or what his
family might do to me if they knew that
I was speaking to the police about what
he'd done
um so
um when and what I'm going just going
back to
um the actual risk I was in so when I'm
speaking to the police I don't realize
what's going to happen next
um I'm too scared to if I you know I've
got this in
ideal in my head that if he's arrested
they'll have to tell him what he's
arrested for so they'll arrest him and
they'll
take him to
prison and everyone will know what he
did
um and that it was me that reported it
yeah and then the other dangerous people
on the street like his brother and his
cousin are going to come around and be
like why have you just reported my
brother or cousin to the police now look
now look what's happened so I was
terrified I was really really scared
um and I don't think I got the right
advice but if I'd have realized that
the The Wider gang was and this was a
plot so it was a bit this was a plot
they'd set Shamil on me because Shamil
is the
um
the aggressor as it were so I don't know
I don't know what they call it the
Rottweiler of the group or whatever you
know so if somebody needs beating up
they'll send him out
um and um if somebody needs to be raped
um so they knew that it would make me
more venerable
um to being abused by them as well so
they
um so two days later
um Ali came around with his friend
um and I was raped Again by Ali and and
his friend
um this is someone you knew already or a
stranger
um so I knew Old Valley
um but again um I'd only been there a
month so this is after just a month of
living in the YMCA yeah so I'd only been
out a month
um
uh so I barely knew any of them yeah um
and I barely had a chance to um you know
I'd had um a couple of introductions Ali
was one of the guys who had called me on
the phone asking for William
um but I didn't really know them at all
um so and I didn't know his friend at
all he was a complete stranger and this
was the first time that like obviously
did anything like that had ever happened
to me
but until you had told the police so did
that did anything happen from that
um I
um
I told the police about Shamil yeah and
um I'd say I told them that I was afraid
of him being arrested
um so they were because I was I was told
by
um the P my counselor
um at college that if I
wanted that I should tell the police at
least for their information
um so that they've got the sort of
Intelligence on him
um and that if I didn't want him to be
arrested then I didn't have to do that
and the reason that I was worried about
him being arrested was because of what
would the repercussions yeah
um I wasn't really
um reassured about it so there wasn't
nothing like oh let me let us help you
tell your family and then maybe you can
go back home
um and where you'll be safe or we could
re-house you somewhere where you could
be feel safe because I lived on the same
street assuming yeah and I lived on the
same street as his as Ali Sultan as well
and um his and his brother and he's got
you know and the other people that could
potentially be a risk to myself to my
life to me physically but when did the
police when you told them did they give
you options or did you get the advice or
was it more like thank you for the
report that's knowing our records well
the advice was
um if you wanted to be arrested
um report it as rape but if you don't so
it was this way around so if you don't
want him to be arrested you have to say
it was consensual right but if you say
that it's rape then we have to arrest
him right okay so they wrote me a
statement
um to say it was consensual which seems
to be common practice really for the
police to actually write your statement
for you but I was quite surprised by
that yeah
um and all I had to do was sign the
statement that had been written for me
right to say that it was consensual and
then it would just go down as
intelligence right okay
so
it sounds like it started to spiral
quite quickly from the point of Shamil
to Ali and his friend coming around
how quickly then did it spiral further
out of control
um I think really it's it it was
spiraling from the first rape so two
days later
um I was raped by Ali and his friend and
then another two days after that
um I was raped by his brother
um a few
um weeks after that Ali would keep
coming back round
um it was it was it wasn't every day but
it was roughly twice a week and
sometimes it would be two men in a day
um and yeah so I'm I'm aware that
uh whether the victims it escalates and
it becomes multiple multiple men
um in a night or in one weekend
um this was the very beginning of the
grooming for me so I was I didn't have
that period of time where they
um
were giving me gifts and
um weaning me into being friends with
them they just went straight in with
um quite traumatic
um rape it incidents and events for me
and sorry this this is going to seem
like an incredibly insensitive question
but why didn't you leave the area at
that point
um I um so I I was planning to leave I
was thinking in my head like I've got to
get out of here but I didn't actually
know how because I um was helped into
the YMCA in the first place so I filled
in a form
um and they found me a flat to live in
so I didn't actually know how to move
house at that time and I didn't know how
to get away I didn't know how to tell my
family because I put a lot of blame on
myself and I think that
the way that I would have described it
to my family because of the blame the
self-blame they would have blamed me as
well so I thought everyone would blame
me I thought it was my fault I thought
I'd got myself into a really bad
situation
um and I was ashamed so I found it
really difficult to actually
say help me I'm I'm like I really
desperately need help
um so I and I didn't know how to help
myself
um so it took me a
um a couple of months
um so not long but it took me a little
while to actually figure out how to move
to move um it couldn't have been an
instant thing for me during the period
this was happening and escalating were
you still attending college
um yeah so
um
it was I was at the end of my eight my a
levels so
um when I for the first I didn't say I
didn't mention that but for the first
the first rape when I was first raped by
Shamil the one that I just described
um it was the weekend before all my
major exams so I had
um six exams in five days
um that that following week and he'd
rape me on the Sunday and my next my
exam was gonna be on the Monday I think
I had a psychology exam on Monday
um and then I had an English exam in his
psychology exam on the Tuesday I had a
biology exam on the Wednesday and then I
went to the police on Wednesday
um and then you know I had some more
exams on the Thursday and Friday and
then I spoke to the and I was raped
again on
Thursday and I went back to the police
and gave the statement on the Saturday
so
um after that
um because all my exams were over I it
was the um it was the
um summer holidays
um and I was waiting for my a level
results
um so I was even um raped the day before
I
um got my a-level results and I you know
walked up to
um College in a bit of a days to like
pick them up and I expected to fail
everything but I didn't luckily
okay so the the experiences
horrifying and probably at that age and
he's probably heard the process in terms
of like what do you do when this has
started happening but what with with a
grooming gang what
what is the purpose for them to begin to
do this to you as you know are they
trying to make you somebody that's like
a slave to them or are they trying to
you know is it simple simply sexual
abuse why when you said that they had um
Shamil as the kind of attack dog that
would go out and and do this
why would they do this to people
so um
I don't know if they are fully aware of
what they're trying to do themselves
um
maybe that's me
not giving them
the amount of intelligence they deserve
or whether it's you know I I get the
feeling that it's um
it's a learned behavior from them so
they just know they know how to do it
because they've been sexually abused
themselves is how I feel but um with the
Telford grooming gang
um they were also the the people who
raped me
um were also already forcibly pimping
out other underage girls
um as well so they were doing that for
money
um and they were
um they had been grooming them probably
and well I know in a very similar way to
the way they groomed me
um to
accept this lifestyle
um and then Contin so they could
continue to abuse you and I think that
these traumatic really traumatic events
that they inflict on you
um is a way of breaking a human being
the same way that you break a horse
so I kind of felt that way I would like
when I when I was like in the pits of my
depression about it I would feel that
I'd been broken
um like you break a horse when um I
don't know if you know how they break
horses but they um so I'm talking about
like a wild horse and making taming a
wild horse so you um tie it to I don't
know everything about
to a post and then you sort of Chase it
right this is the um simplistic version
you chase it round in a circle until
eventually it physically like is
physically exhausted and then it gives
up and then you can tame it from then
and you can teach it
um how you can teach it the tricks and
it's Wilson broken yeah yeah um so I
feel like that's what they did to me
they
broke my will to well broke my will to
live and then
all the will to defend myself and then I
gave up and I gave up on myself and I
think
there's even a very
I think I I feel like I can even
pinpoint the moment it happened
um and
um the moment I've felt like this was my
life now and
on now I'm a and I can't actually
change that and there's nothing else I
can do and that's it from now on
um and that's what that's
kind of how how they
bring you into it sorry that I might not
feel like I went off on a tangent no no
it's it's it makes complete sense and
it's a really clear description for like
because for me it's just so hard the two
things that are so hard to process is
the pain of what you were put through
and the cruelty that these people
inflicted on of the humans and the
explanation on both sides there about
the fact that it was a learned behavior
and the breaking the horse which is a
very good analogy make it does make it
very understandable so I know we we've
met before and uh I remember you talked
about a party incident
and I was wondering if you tell us about
that
um so uh I was taken to a party
um by
a guy that I'd essentially
met very recently well that that day
actually
um but I'd been so I'd been raped
um actually I was actually
four months into being raped
um twice a week or three times a week
um so I was quite psychologically
damaged at that point and going through
quite a lot
um and not sure where my head was at
um and a very vulnerable state in my
um ordeal really but um
he took me to a party
um and
um
there were he so first of all he um took
me he wanted to he wanted to get me
drunk but I didn't actually drink so he
taken me to
um the Tesco to like pick up some
alcohol and um sorry was this a member
of the gang or was this someone you'd
met separately I'm well it all it all
looks separate sure so you felt like you
wasn't a member of got you okay yeah
yeah so it felt like I'd met him
separately but actually I'm on the same
street so why would I even think that
but um
uh so he took me to Tesco
um and I sat in the car and waited for
him to come out and he picked up some
Smirnoff um vodka which
um
is a tactic that they use for
for their victims and they used and it
probably worked under the victims but I
hated alcohol and I specifically hated
vodka so um oh she's rolling my eyes and
thinking oh God he's bought vodka
um and um but I didn't I didn't say
anything and then um and then he drove
me all around he took me onto a dual
carriageway and then he I don't know how
like drove a really long way basically
to somewhere an area that I actually
knew
um which was not that far away from my
house
um it was actually
um
uh
next to the Morrisons which was my local
um shopping center that I walked to I'm
shopping what do you call it supermarket
and I'll walk to and um
and I thought why is he why is he taking
me all this way around and it didn't
make sense to me at the time but it I
mean afterwards in hindsight it does
because you know because you can always
look in hindsight and see all the
problems
um and they're all the warning signs but
at the time I was just confused I was
like like no idea why I did that
um when the place is right here um but
he was actually trying to confuse me
seem like you were going far away yeah
he was trying to make me feel lost right
um and he's trying to make me feel
helpless like I couldn't I wouldn't be
able to walk home but I because yeah and
you were drinking presumably at this
point were you drinking the vodkas oh
God no oh okay no I'll tell you
um so I so he poured me a drink at the
party so we got to the party there were
lots of different people there they
weren't um they weren't they were all a
mix of different people
um but it was mostly men
um there were two other women there who
were older than me
um and they were already very very drunk
and so I never really got to know those
two other ladies that were there
um and he poured me a drink and he
pulled me a drink it was like a normal
sort of tumbler glass where he was a
tall one and he pulled half vodka and
half lemonade in it there was a and I
look and I watched him pour it and I
thought there's absolutely nowhere
either I'm gonna be able to drink that
um and I because I I hated the taste it
made you know I couldn't even yeah I
couldn't even imagine drinking it but um
I was embarrassed by that because I was
a teenager and it was cool to drink
um so I didn't let them know that I
wasn't gonna drink it I just sort of
styled it a bit and I was like you know
how you always find him in the party in
the kitchen at party so I was like
hanging out in the kitchen with the
drink in my hand next to the sink and
pretending to take a sip and then
pouring it when no one was looking
pouring into the sink
um but that was me being like very
embarrassed about
um not being able to actually drink
um so I think in a way it was
I don't know if I
I don't think it helped I don't think it
actually made any difference I think the
only difference it made is that one um I
remembered what was what happened more
vividly and it was a lot more painful
um so I don't feel like it
not drinking didn't really help me
um in in either way it might have helped
if they'd have known that I wasn't
drinking because if they'd have known
that I was like fully Compass mentors
that maybe they would have changed their
mind about what they were going to try
and make me do maybe they would have had
more respect for me because they used
um
the girl being drunk as an excuse to say
that that's enough reason they shouldn't
be drunk and that's why they're they
deserve to be raped so maybe if they
knew but on you know it might not I
don't think it would have made any
difference
um
but yeah so try to get me drunk they
thought so that's another warning sign
really but I didn't recognize it I
thought it was cool to drink and that's
why they were trying to get me drunk and
was he being fairly friendly at this
point yeah yeah not aggressive no no no
it was lovely and you know he's being
nice and his friends were lovely as well
and they were all like being welcoming
and
um there was music on and it was like a
normal house party
um and then he sort of convinced me into
the bedroom a bit later on
um I don't know maybe I haven't got
enough excuse maybe I haven't you know
made well I was
you know I wasn't
um
I was vulnerable and I was already
um being being raped on a regular basis
and um part of me was trying to take
back control all the time so I was very
confused about whether I should consent
to sex or whether I shouldn't and what
the difference was anymore because I put
a lot of blame on myself full times that
I'd actually been raped which I thought
were consensual because they really
pushed me into it or I'd given up at
some point and
um
um I'd allowed it to happen to myself
and that's how I'd felt about all these
scenarios so I was trying to
um very sort of naively trying to be
like I I like to have sex when I want to
have sex so if I go out and find it then
you know maybe that's
um will make me feel better about sex as
a whole
um
anyway
I think they count on that I think this
is another way that they're actually
grooming you into being very confused
about consent
um so he tricked me into the bedroom I I
went into the bedroom with him he
obviously knew what he was going to do
um and he'd lied to me the entire time
um and
um and then
um he
um raped me anally it's really difficult
to talk about
um and I think one one reason I talk
about it is because it is so humiliating
that that humiliate that humiliating
feeling
um used to be a um like a feeling that
would induce Suicidal Thoughts in myself
okay and now I share that because that
humiliation stops you from seeking help
okay
um and now I just now I don't care
because I think if I if I put my myself
through admitting what happened then
um that humiliation can no longer rule
me anymore
um so that's why that's one of the
reasons I talk about this particular
rate because I think it is really
humiliating and I think that it's a it's
one thing that happens to some rape
victims and they don't want to come
forward because they blame themselves
for like literally putting themselves in
the bedroom alone with them in that
vulnerable situation and then this this
is what happens and that therefore it's
their fault which is which is wrong
um
and I'll just sorry I'll just describe
it though uh you don't have to no no I
won't describe I'm like no I'm going to
describe
um why it's a crime okay
um in the sexual offenses act
um you can consent to some things and
not consent to other things okay and um
if you make your consent clear then
um or your non-consent clear then they
and the person who is the perpetrator
knows that you are not consenting then
that's rape and you can also in the
sexual offenses Act
consent to something and then withdraw
your consent at any time and then it's
rape then it becomes rape so you can so
you can consent to a sexual act at the
beginning but if you try and you you
signal that you want to stop
and they don't stop then they know that
you're not consenting anything and that
becomes rape
um so it's not really up for debate for
the individual people who were thinking
whether you deserve it or you deserve it
in the eyes of the law that was
non-consensual sex which is rape yeah
um so yeah so um I was raped anally by
him I tried to escape I screamed I
shouted I said stop
um one reason was because at the
beginning I thought it was an accident
so I didn't actually expect him to
continue to try and have sex with me
after I was saying that it was
um that you know that I was in pain
um he knew what I was going to do and he
knew that I was going to try and pull
away which which now I can look in
hindsight and say he had experience so
he knew that it was going to be be
painful and he knew what a victim does
when that pain hits you which is to pull
away and he knew I was going to pull
away and he
was already prepared for that so he
pushed his body to into mine knowing
that if he did that I couldn't escape
and I smacked my head on the headboard I
was trapped and he knew that I was
trapped there and he then I just had to
wait until he was finished
um and you know that's horrible and that
is intentional rape that is intentional
rape from someone who is an experienced
serial rapist
um and that's the reason that I share
that that incident
even to this day and unfortunately
I did report that to the police but it
um
but they couldn't find enough evidence
that we even knew each other he said
that he'd never met me before
and they couldn't put because no one at
the party would come forward either they
couldn't put me in him in the same room
together ever so I couldn't even prove
that I knew him or you know I don't know
what why because I id'd him in an ID
parade
um yeah and it's still yeah yeah so I am
what do you call it when you sort of
positively ID them in an ID parade and
but that still wasn't enough evidence to
to take it forward or that's what the
police said to me
um sometimes they don't tell you the
truth yeah
um which is the yeah you you come across
as very strong by the way oh thank you
when you're telling the story you come
across as a very strong person oh thank
you
hi there this is Ben Paul Jones we're
just going to take a quick break from
today's episode to talk a little bit
about our sponsor a brand new six-part
podcast from message heard and podimo
who robs a Banksy follows journalist
Jake Warren as he sets out to explore
the Stranger Than Fiction tale of the
man who kidnapped a Banksy statue from
the middle of Central London in broad
daylight and held it to Ransom the ACT
would lead to an almost 20-year war of
bad blood relations and legal battles
that are still being waged today and it
all comes down to one man and one
Vendetta but it doesn't end there the
story will take us on a journey through
the UK's most subversive subcultures
from our heists and art terrorists to
80s football hooliganism and the 90s
illegal Rave scene and throughout it all
Jake will be trying to get hold of the
most Elusive and famed Anonymous artists
in the world in this new six-part series
host Jake Warren speaks to the Tiger
King of the art scene Andy link and
those closest to Banksy himself exposing
their two decade-long Feud and
attempting to track down the world's
most elusive Anonymous artist who robs
the bank sees him available from the 3rd
of May wherever you get your podcasts to
hear the whole series early and AD free
subscribe to podomo UK on Apple podcasts
now back to the episode
sorry you were asking me about the party
no that's fine I
I guess
in trying to understand the things that
these people do in the sort of like
depths that they'll go to why do you
think that he bothered pretending to be
nice and pretending to be different from
the Gang
they want you to
vent for as long as possible
I think it's not in first of all they um
I think they enjoy the the chase as it
were they enjoy the pretense so they um
use it as a um
again a reason to disrespect you that
use it as a as a way of laughing at you
behind your back
um they use it as
um look at this silly girl she deserves
it so they're looking for reasons all
the time why you deserve to be abused
um and
um and if you're consenting for the
longest and complying for the longest
period of time they have less work to do
to get what they want out of you it
makes it easier for them to abuse you at
the last minute do you think
I mean it's probably conjects here but
do you think
they view women
as lesser beings like lower life forms I
mean the thought of putting people
through these things do you think they
were treating men in the same way maybe
not with sexual abuse but in other ways
or do you think it's specifically women
so I think
involved I think there is a hatred there
for women
um but I also think there's an element
of
um
um it's called the social personality
disorder
um but it used to be called Psychopathic
personality disorder um so where they
really cannot identify with the um with
the feelings and of in of other
individuals and actually
um
sort of aiming to please themselves all
the time and they can't
um
identify with other people's pain it's
like a complete lack of empathy yes
complete lack of empathy yeah um and I
believe that you know there's several
things at play there for the reason why
they can why they can actually do this
to women or anyone okay well that I mean
awful story and an awful experience
um but I'm aware that at some point you
started to try to plan an escape didn't
you for to go to university
so how did that come about
um so I was um so I got my a-level
results
um after being raped the night before
um uh very surprised by them because I
thought I would fail them all and you
know I did I did get a D in Psychology
because I literally was in one of the
exams I'd written a suicide note rather
than actually
um rather than actually do the exam
did you give that in yeah I mean it was
a bit cryptic so it wasn't it wasn't
obvious that I was you know I wasn't
saying I'm going to kill myself now
because maybe they would have flagged
that up and done you'd hope so yeah
um it was more like a um
it was actually more like a sorry sorry
to have let you down and
um I was really upsetting to remember
now but sorry to have like wasted your
time
um because you're going to open this
um exam paper and it's completely blank
so
um
that it was along those lines so I just
sort of written a cryptic suicide note
but it probably just looked like or an
apology basically
um so I knew that I'd failed that exam
um and
uh hang on a minute where am I and then
but you had gotten yeah upgrade yeah
yeah I got a C in English and I was like
yes I wouldn't even expect that but I
was like oh
um something uh over a
you know it's much better than I was
expecting right
um and um because before that my plan
had I had some little plans in my head
and I was thinking let me go back to
college and retake my
um last year and then at least most of
the time I'll be out like if I can
continue being a full-time student I'll
be out of my flat yeah most of the time
so um they won't be able to find me at
home as they were doing during the
summer holidays
um and um my next my next plan was maybe
I couldn't get a job and I'll be out
most of the time yeah
um I'd got a part-time job but I mean
you know a better job that had more
hours
um and um but then when I got my a-level
results
um I'd gone back to college to try and
go back and they'd say well you've got
decent a level results so we're not
going to fund you for another year right
and they were a bit like matter of fact
with me and I was like oh no and then I
was like I can't know that plan's not
gonna work and and they said we'll put
you with the student advisor so that you
can find out what university you can go
to
um and when I met the student advisor oh
she was lovely a really really nice lady
um I was actually quite I'd had a fight
with William at the time and I was all
bruised up
um
yeah yeah oh wow a physical fight um
which I don't feel too bad about because
I don't feel like I was beaten up I feel
like it was a fair fight we'd literally
oh yeah I hit him first
um and then you know it was you know
it's all going on anyway
um but she felt bad for me because I was
bruised I was bruised up so I'd clearly
been in some sort of physical
altercation
um I was a young girl and she was like
you should look after yourself better
um and um she
uh said do you want to go to university
this year or next year at that point it
was September so um I had to double take
for a minute and I said
yeah like how much like there was only
four months of the year left I was like
what do you mean this year and she was
like yeah you can apply through
something called clearing
um which is where there there's some
spaces left at University on the courses
so they're trying to get rid of them as
quickly as possible so you can apply
um and um I wanted to do so
psychology then that's why I was doing
a-level psychology
um but all the places were sort of taken
up for psychology and I didn't want to
um I didn't want to wait a year no and I
didn't want to go to a university that
was nearby yeah so I didn't want to go
to Wolverhampton University and I didn't
want to go to Birmingham University
um nothing against those universities
they were just yes too close too local
yeah too close and I thought that they
can come and get me if um if I go to
either of those locations so
um we looked at mental health nursing
and there were lots of places and I
think we might have picked the first
University on the list which was or one
of the first universities on the list
which was Anglia Ruskin a in
alphabetical order
um and um she really bent over backwards
to get me in to the university yeah
actually so she'd seen something there
yeah and at this point how long had it
gone on for with the Telford gang
um so
so non-4
it's five months
um you did manage to escape
so to speak to University
and you got a place in University and
you moved there which you hoped would be
the end of the situation but
unfortunately it wasn't was it uh no
um I I mean so to begin with
um I was very glad that I'd escaped so
um
um was like you can't imagine the relief
yeah actually of and I I really liked
the town I I like suddenly had this
appreciation for life like so I loved
the town I loved the um the bricks in
the in the street yeah where was this
sorry again um it was since
yeah and it's um some of the buildings
are like fairly new or they were anyway
at the time and
um so maybe the maybe the floor had been
recently changed in the High Street or
something and I was just in love with
everything I just thought oh my God this
is great
um I even even at University they had
these um automatic hand
uh sanitize the gel and the toilets
would come out and it smelled like um it
was a cherry flavor and I'd even
remember the smell of that and
um thought it was great because it
reminded me of like when we were kids
and we had some shampoo that was Cherry
um flavored smelled what's this scented
scented yeah okay
um and um so I was really glad I was
like I felt lucky to be alive I thought
oh my god I've like actually made it
I've got it out of there
um and um very quickly though
um I started to develop symptoms of PTSD
but I didn't realize what that was at
the beginning so it started off with
um
it started off with flashbacks but I
wasn't conscious of the flashback so I
didn't know that I was having memories
um and
um I
thought the first I would know about it
was that I would be first I'd be fine
sort of trying to do some work on the
computer in my room um in Halls at
University and then the next thing I
know I would be sitting underneath my
desk
crying
and then I would be like why am I crying
so I wouldn't even feel
the emotion of crying so I wouldn't even
like so it would be it was very lost
space like
a blackout period yeah yeah um and I um
so this was happening so probably about
twice a week
um and
um sort of a few weeks into it
I caught myself shouting at Ally so like
shouting at Ali Sultan who was one of
the men who'd abused me
um but there was no one there obviously
this was a past event and I was
repeating the same words that I'd said
to him at the time or and it just
suddenly made me aware that I was having
a memory and this wasn't like a
nightmare this was like a way awake yeah
suddenly having a a vivid flashback yeah
yeah so um I
I realized what I was remembering and so
I realized the incident that I was
remembering
and I didn't even realize that was an
issue so I didn't realize I've been
traumatized by that situation because
I'd been so groomed in like and into
believing that everything I was doing
was consensual that that incident that
had happened was just like another day
while I was living there but all of a
sudden I was having these memories about
it and I thought it was bizarre so I
like I was shouting at Ally and I
thought
why am I shouting at Annie why am I why
am I having this memory why does why am
I even bothered about it why am I crying
and you know it was
a bit of a a shocking moment for me you
know it stays with me now so I'll just
you know really had no idea what was
going on
um
and I think you know that's when I
started
realizing that I was more bothered by
what had happened than than I realized
and I'd first realized
um and
I called them I called them episodes
because I didn't know how to explain
what they were and it was happening so
early on when I started uni that even
though I was zoom into Health nursing we
hadn't got to that bit yet so we were
actually doing a foundation course in um
in the first year
um which had all the different nursing
aspects of it so we weren't doing mental
health nursing we were doing
um like General adult nursing
um and so we hadn't got to that bit so I
didn't know what was
what the hell is going on
um and I didn't recognize them as a
panic attack
because maybe it wasn't a panic attack
um but I didn't feel in panic I felt
upset and I felt distressed but I didn't
even know if I knew what to call it
distress so you basically basically it
sounds as though you didn't have the
tools to identify what was happening
yeah to identify kind of trauma or yeah
host traumatic stress and things like
that yeah exactly exactly
um so certain things would trigger me
off as well and I couldn't identify
triggers
um but um one one trigger was like when
I you know because you just have to live
it because you're living it every day
when you're being raped every day but
you still have to get up and carry on
and
um feed yourself and you know every time
I open the fridge or every time I cooked
pasta on the on the Hub when I was
eating
um I would maybe have a memory of the
time that I was eating pasta in the YMCA
but I knew I was being about to be or I
had just got raped afterwards or after
I'd been raped or I had something to eat
so I'd always have this feeling that it
was still going on um and then I would
end up in my room again on the floor
crying my eyes out because I tried to
make pasta
um and um
I thought it was really weird and I
didn't know how to explain it to anyone
and were you were you at that point in
time were you building relationships and
friendships in University or you kind of
just keeping yourself away keeping your
head down
so I I was trying at Uni
um but I
um felt really I couldn't help it I felt
really different to everyone yeah of
course I felt like
um other people are
um other people my own age are um
just come from their parents house and
they are
um like free and innocent and they want
to go out and party and I was probably a
bit terrified of partying and because of
the party incident
um and I was probably a bit more
terrified of drinking as well because of
the incident
um and so I wasn't interested in any of
the things they were doing and I just
felt very
different to them
um and I felt like if they knew
what had happened or who I was because I
was this really bad person that had been
behaving very like sexually bad
um then they wouldn't like me so I
thought I was a bad person and that I
was keeping this really bad horrible
secret about who I was
um I felt like I'd got a second chance
to start again and not let people have
that reputation of about me but I was
keeping that I had to keep that a secret
from people so
um I found it really difficult to make
friends for that reason yeah it makes
complete sense and and what was the
point that
because eventually what happened was you
got connected to a different gang didn't
you yeah so
um
while I was still in the YMCA in Telford
um there had um it was Shamil had
um
being in prison with
so he he introduced me to his cousin he
was still in prison his cousin who was
in prison
um Kate was coming out on day release
because he was in a cat D prison where
they allowed them to come out
um he was
um friends with or connected with
someone else in prison who was part of
another gang and
um he I don't know sold my number or
sold my details or gave him it's traded
my details for something else in prison
um and um sort of set up a meeting with
me and um another man from Birmingham
and that's how I ended up with the
Birmingham introduced to the Birmingham
gang
um when I met that man
he was a lot nicer to me
um than the Telford gang
um he
um would tell me that they were wrong
for the way they were treating me I
would confide in him so I found
friendship in him
um and I found that I felt like I could
be myself with them because I could be
honest about
my life in the YMCA with them and they
wouldn't find it weird they they had
they understood because they were living
the life as well
um
obviously not under the same
circumstances as myself but from being
in that Circle as it were
um and
um so I was introduced to him and then I
was introduced to other members of his
gang
um other members of his family and they
were nice to me and they were okay with
me and I found it easier to hang out
with them because they weren't
as
hateful and um sort of intentionally
abusive as the gang in Telford
um so the gang in Telford were really
evil to me they were like they intended
to inflict harm on me they were laughing
at me embarrassing me um humiliating me
making me feel intentionally worthless
and then I had this gang in Birmingham
who were being nice to me and welcoming
and
um sort of
not being forceful or pushy yeah
um but still expecting from me what the
other gang had
um but because I was more
experienced now
um with the extreme experience that I'd
had from the Telford gang
I knew how they wanted me to behave
um and how to behave in a way that would
make them have more respect for me it's
it's complicated to explain but this is
the effects of the the manipulation what
actually happened
um through the the trauma that they put
me through
um was intentional to get me to start
behaving in a way that
um they was socially acceptable in their
Circle yeah that makes sense and then
that made me feel comfortable in their
Circle and segregated me from everyone
else and were you still when you with
the Birmingham gang
were you at University at this point
when you started to were they were you
still in contact with them or did you
move up to Birmingham yeah so to begin
with no
um I was still Intel I was still in
Telford yeah um and then I moved to
um Essex this is my chance to escape
yeah
um and then I started having really
terrible mental health in Essex yes I
couldn't get on with the
um people in Essex I felt different from
everyone it wasn't anything to do with
them or their fault
um but I just had this terrible feeling
in myself
um and I still the Birmingham gang was
calling me to them and I felt more
comfortable with them and I felt like I
could be myself with them because I felt
like that was my honest true self was
that I was worthless yeah and that I and
if other people
um I was trying to keep up these
pretense in in Essex that I was somebody
and I found that really difficult and I
found that really like the like a
responsibility on my shoulders because
the Birmingham gang knew your secret so
you just need to hide it from them yeah
because they were part of that lifestyle
yes yeah and did they
did they maintain
the same level of kindness that you've
described if we can I mean kindness is
the wrong word but you understand what I
mean and that they weren't like the
Telford gang or was there a changing
point so
um some of them remained kind and some
of them turned nasty
um but then I would have
the ones that were nasty so I'd have
like a really bad experience with them I
might actually get raped by them
um and then I would turn back to my
friends that were nice to me
um and I would stick with them even
though they had introduced me to the
nasty one if that makes sense but they
would say things manipulative things
like I I'm sorry that my cousin treated
you that way I'm sorry that um that
happened I didn't know he was going to
do that but please Don't Judge Me by his
behavior because it wasn't me it was him
um so they would make me
feel that I had us to be loyal to them
because they were loyal to me because
they hadn't been the ones that hurt me
it was someone else so although it's a
different gang and you had had you moved
to Birmingham at this point is that no
no you was too coming back you were
coming back and forth so even though it
was a different gang ultimately it was
still the same manipulation to get the
same in end game and yeah
how how long were you then involved with
the Birmingham gang for
him gang for on and off for um about
five years wow okay
um I um for the first year
um so I was abused um in um Telford in
2007 and then for the first year after
that the whole of 2008 I was deeply
involved with them
um and then after 2008 my my mental
health was really deteriorating I was
really suicidal
um I really strongly hated myself
um and I wanted to try and do something
about it I was also learning at
University
um
uh
techniques to help mental health yeah um
so
um I was
becoming wiser as to sort of having
ideas of how to get out of the gang and
that I wanted to be out of the gang and
I wanted to do something that didn't
make me feel as bad
and when you say you knew you wanted to
be out of the gang you know
I know it's a very very complex topic
but I know some people would look and
say well why didn't you just leave what
stops you just leaving when you're a
somebody that's being victimized by a
gang like that
um so it's it's something I would have
thought myself as well like sometimes I
was in in surrounded by them in a room
and thinking to myself what am I doing
here why don't I just leave
um I you know and it was another reason
that I really hated myself because I
could not and I couldn't understand it
um but I was it was another form of PTSD
it was another symptom of PTSD but I was
physically reliving the events or
reliving what had happened to me
phys like
action through my actions and that was
making me feel more comfortable than
when I was in Essex
having terrible flashbacks and feeling
very distressed about it so it I mean
it's it's hard to just explain
psychologically how it works yeah but I
would have if I didn't when I tried to
stay away from the gang
um I would start having nightmares I
would start having
um the flashbacks again
um I would have really distressing
episodes where I could barely breathe I
was so upset
um and when I was in the gang in
Birmingham that didn't happen anymore
um but it still happened because there
was some incidents that were so
dangerous I was putting myself in such
dangerous situations that I thought one
one day
I could get killed
and
what would what would happen then
because they wouldn't
like this is upsetting to think about
but like these friends of mine they
would probably Panic or freak out if
they killed me by accident or if they
kill me on purpose what are they gonna
do with my body
um they're not gonna call the ambulance
they're not gonna call the police and
say oh um we've got this dead girl here
they're gonna dump me somewhere and um
there and then and then my parents are
gonna find me dumped somewhere not my
parents finding me but like find out
that there's been a body found and it's
me and um
and then my parents will never
understand or never know what happened
to me so
that was a really upsetting thought
um and that was the biggest
um drive that stopped that made me want
to get out of the gang because I did not
want
that my for my parents to go through
that
um
and I I felt really distressed about the
way my life was going as well and I
didn't want this it wasn't what I had
planned um yes as a as a teenager or you
know when you think about
um your future this is not what I had
planned
um and every day I could just
see myself potentially becoming a sex
worker and that being my life and that's
not what I and I don't mean one of the
um sex workers that make loads of money
I mean like I don't know on the street
doing drugs
um and it's not what I wanted for my
life so it really encouraged me to stay
at University and at one time I saw it
very very black and white that I was
either at University going to become a
nurse or or I was going to be a
prostitute
um and I only had those options
available to me
wow I mean that's
quite when you say there's two options I
mean there's just such such Worlds Apart
that you were living this incredible
double life where the other people at
your University that were the same age
as you probably had no idea that that
was a
strong potential outcome for you yeah
yeah and what so what it sounds like for
a lot of people very understandably
remaining in that space it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy where you get
more and more brainwashed and
indoctrinated into that lifestyle
so how did you finally decide to
move out of that area and I don't know
what to call it but you know you you
some of these people have been brought
to Justice haven't they yes so how did
that all come about okay so
um after the year of 2008 when I was not
having you know I was doing really bad
um and then um and then I started to try
and get away from the gank
um I was managing to go quite a few
months
um it was like an addiction so it was
like um I was going cold turkey and like
I would manage to go a few months cold
turkey without going back
um there was drugs involved as well so
perhaps it was drugs pulling me back
but I didn't accept that at the time
um
and
um I decided to I reported it in 2010
um what had happened to me in Telford
because
um I was a third year nursing student by
then and um I had learned a lot about
risks and what
um risks individual people present and
what is a risk and you know
um so somebody who's commit a sexual
offense
is at risk of doing it again so
there's people that I knew that had
commit sexual offenses against me so I
have the most proof because it happened
against me
um and they're at risk of doing it again
and some of them I thought or had the
feeling that they'd done it before so
um I already knew that they probably got
other victims so I started to feel
like a responsibility on myself as a as
in becoming a nurse
um that I had a responsibility to the
public to at least report it
um so I and then I thought if I reported
to the police
um even if it doesn't go anywhere
um at least I can
have that burden relieved off myself
um so um I went back to the police I
reported it
um I went to the Essex police Essex
police obviously um didn't really know
anything about Telford so they took down
my details and they took down the
details of
um the people I was reporting and they
um said oh we'll get back to you but
don't hold up any hopes because this is
historic it had been three years by then
um and then
um the Telford police got in touch with
me quite quickly and they were actually
in the middle of an investigation okay
um for the men that I had reported right
so
um Ali Sultan was already had already
been reported um and it was already
under under investigation similar crimes
yes yeah for similar crimes um and um
operation chalice had just started
taking effect so
um they um would
um
came down as quickly as they could
basically to come and interview me
um it was probably a response that I
wasn't expecting
um but they probably weren't expecting
me to come forward either they were
asking me if um if I knew and they were
asking for other people to come forward
so they thought that that's why I
responded but actually it was completely
coincidence okay yeah
so I had no idea
um and I think my PTSD
um was untreated at the time
um and I was feeling better because I
probably because I wasn't doing drugs
anymore and um I was also
um
staying away from that lifestyle at the
time
um and um
I had no idea
how and where I'd been with PTSD um so I
didn't realize that I was such a risk of
re-traumatization and that's what
happened when I reported it to the
police they told me about this new in
this investigation that was already
ongoing then I realized that it was
happening to other girls and girls a lot
younger than me and for me that was
absolutely devastating like I can't
actually explain
how bad that actually feels because not
only do we is it an absolute shock to
everyone in the country
um
I knew what they'd done to me so the
thought of them doing it to other
children are the girls and girls a lot
younger than myself was absolutely
heartbreaking I was really hoping that
it was just me
um and I thought it was me I thought it
was me I thought it was my fault I
thought I'd done things I didn't not
realize that
um that children were being treated in
the same way by the same man
um and I found that really difficult to
cope with at the time
things my mental health really spiraled
um and
um
I
ended up attempting suicide
um
and it was a it was my first I'd been
feeling suicidal for about three years
and it was my first big and really my
only big suicide attempt and at the time
I was how so I think that I was
suffering some sort of
um
some psychotic symptoms some mild
psychotic symptoms because I believed
that
Shamil was had a demon inside him and
that when he raped me he had put a demon
inside me and when and that demon would
make me behave in ways that I would not
want
to behave in so I in in Humane ways that
would actually hurt me
um I think you know part of it was
actually you know my PTSD and this was
my way of explaining it but the at the
time that I attempted suicide I thought
I was had this urge to go back to the
gang which I think was
a symptom of like reliving it but I
thought it was a demon making me trying
to make me go back
um and I really did not want to be
abused again and I really did not want
that life and I thought the only way to
stop myself was to kill myself so
um it I had a massive um I took a
massive overdose
um of 58 tablets of code idramal
um which made me very sick
um I I called a friend because I had
this one
I lay down to like go to sleep and I
just thought what a sad way to end it
and then I thought
maybe I'd maybe that maybe that me
saying what a sad way to end it means
that I don't really want to die and then
I thought okay I'm
very cool my friend so so I called my
friend
um and she called an ambulance for me
and I went to a e and I was very very
sick I was very unwell I was
um I couldn't stop being sick it was
very traumatic
um and I thought afterwards
what did I have to be afraid of if I'm
afraid of this gang
I have just realized that I've just
proven to myself that I am the most
dangerous person to me
um
I am the one who's just made us
an attempt to my life so am I
my own attempted murderer if that makes
sense like no one else is necessarily
attempted to murder me but I have tried
to murder myself so I'm actually
who else have I got to be afraid of so
it in one way it spurred me on to
continue to um
go ahead with the court case and the
investigation and in another way it was
bad for me because I realized
the um being abused is probably better
than being dead so I just went back to
the gang
um I just did what I was thinking and I
just went back and
um
I don't know if I might have still been
a little bit
like mentally unwell I think definitely
I was because I started to come to like
a couple of months later and realized
what have I just been doing for the last
few months like there were probably
loads of other
um loads of things happened
um I I wrote about some of that in in my
book
um and um
uh I'm very very lucky that to be alive
after that but the point that you
finally left the Birmingham gang
how many people do you think you've been
abused by
um so
um the um the number the number 70 was
coined um oh like a long time ago in
2013 when I was
um
sort of recruited into
speak in a documentary for um the hunt
for Britain sex gangs and I had created
this map which I which is one of the
things that I'd done to try and
um
visualize it to myself and actually when
I'd written it down it was kind of
looked like a map of a gang which I
didn't expect it to it's like a drug
gang you know everybody's connected to
everyone else in total there were 70
people on it
um and I'd kind of
um marked an x on all the ones that I
thought were rape and all the ones that
I thought were
um I was very scared and I changed the I
changed the colors to say this is a
situation that I was terrified in this
is a situation where I was violently
raped in and you know there was 70 on
there and the
um the reporter from my explanation of
it was saying you're describing these
situations that seem consensual that you
describe as consensual but actually
they pushed you and coerced you into
this so you're describing a gang rape
um and that was quite heavy for me but
that's how that's how the number 70 sort
of came about
um but some of it was
because I because I was over 18
um by law it would be very complicated
to differentiate
um the times that I was very vulnerable
and a vulnerable adult and therefore
could not consent
um and the times where I did consent and
the times where it was definitely rape
and it would be
um so I didn't report anyone from the
Birmingham gang
it would be dangerous too for me because
there's so many of them yeah
um that if I reported any of them all of
them would be against me yeah um and
then I'd be at risk if I walked down
Birmingham I'm probably at risk anyway
um but I um kind of have to ignore that
um and live my life um so I do so I
won't
I I won't show Fear because
so far I've had a track record that
nobody's nobody's coming threatened made
a threat against me so so
um I don't I'm not going to worry about
it even if other people are worried for
me and maybe I should be worried I'm not
going to worry because I can't live my
life like that
um but yeah that's one reason I haven't
reported it another reason is because
they might not be
um they might not have
um
might not be convicted anyway there's
not much evidence it's very difficult
um to um find enough evidence for those
individual incidents where maybe I can
send it to sleep with this man and then
the man who had sex with me afterwards I
didn't want to sleep with him so that
was rape but how are we going to prove
that yeah if I just had sexual consented
sex with someone else so it was too it's
too complicated I think to try
that makes a lot of sense but of the
ones that you did report in the in the
Telford gang yeah how many were
imprisoned and what were their sentences
yeah so um I um I I actually reported
um eight people eight or nine people
um only three of them went to court
right
um and two of them were found guilty
um and one of them was found not guilty
um
um yeah so to um show Shamil and Ali
were found guilty
um Shamil got um sentenced to 11 years
in prison
um and um
Ali got sentenced to
um
six years in prison and a I think 11
years on license I think
um I might be wrong I've forgotten now
um because
um Ali then was reported again
um by someone else um and he's still in
prison at the moment even though he
served his sentence for me
um but
um because he was reported again
um he's he's still in prison for another
for another sentence basically because
he abused so many women
um and are the ones that have reported
him are just the um
uh uh oh nothing in comparison to the
amount of people he actually abused yeah
yeah
um
it's quite shocking
to hear the story and you know when you
get to the bit in the story and you say
you thought it was just you because
if someone like me has never been around
anything like that you just don't
imagine it's happening um
do you think it's
still happening and do you think it's
happening more than is reported on you
know what's your view on that
yeah so it's still happening it's
definitely still happening
um I think they just find they've just
found ways to hide it or ways of
threatening their
um their victims in in a different way
like if you I think
if you report like they could they might
say things like if you report me
it's gonna be it's gonna blow up and
it's gonna like in the media and it's
gonna be all over it so you so there's
more
um there's more pressure If you decide
to report it
um than there was before I mean there
was no pressure before because you'd be
ignored anyway so it was probably like
you might as well report me because
they're not going to do anything
um in fact some some victims reported it
and then were sentenced um were were
charged themselves with something
um and um and have convictions because
of things they did while they were being
abused so
um or as a result of being abused or a
result of like getting upset and
smashing something because they were
abused and then
um which is horrendous horrendous to
think about that that
the victims are so heavily blamed by
society as well as the men who are
abusing them
um that we will then actually charge
them and convict them for something
and when you look back over all of your
experiences
you know what's something you've learned
from it when you look back over
everything that happened and you've come
out of it as a stronger person who now
is a um you know just grab yourself
earlier as a campaign or would that be
the right word
um I I don't really know what I would
describe myself yes but I um because I I
always have these
um ideas that I would like to do
something
um in the media to help people and then
I I don't do it because I'm actually
very shy and um I um uh don't have I'm
trying to fight that confidence still
um but I um I really really want to help
people I want to use my skills in mental
health nursing and the
um the the people who I meet who are
become my patients
um I want to help them and I want to at
least them to know that
um because I because I've been through
Plex trauma that when they've been
through complex trauma I can use what I
know to help them yeah and I can use
this the skills that I've learned in my
life as well as the skills that I've
learned through training
um and actually make
make that a comprehensive sort of way of
being able to support those people
um and the people that I meet through my
work
um I I try to do things
um I'm trying to do more I think I will
in the future because I feel like I'm
still young
um and I've even had a way to go with my
own mental health before I've been at a
stage where I can properly help people
the way I want to
um and the way I Envision but I want to
help other victims I want to help with
the survivors I want to help those girls
that no one listens to and I want to
help the girls that are judged by
everyone
um
and they're not helped because they're
judged and not helped because their
behavior has become so complicated and
so difficult that other people turn them
away when really I know where that where
that comes from because even I've
struggled with my own behavior and I've
had to learn interpersonal skills and um
myself to actually overcome that and I
want to be able to pass that on and show
um other victims and other survivors
that actually
you can achieve what I have and actually
get to a place in your mind and in your
life where you're not suffering anymore
from your own mental health and from
suicidal thoughts and from that
worthlessness
um I used to think that I was worthless
and I used to believe that everybody
else was better than me and that I would
never amount to anything
um and then
by
um I don't know not by luck by I think
by never giving up I have actually come
out of the other side of it and I've
managed to persevere and I didn't die
when I took that overdose and
um I actually made it through the storm
just by getting up every day and living
and carrying on and then time sort of
did the rest
um
so I I want other people to believe that
they can be something and that they can
actually
um over overcome what what the
what the evil people who have abused
them wanted them to believe about
themselves
um because it is possible and I don't
think that I'm a special case that um
I'm the only one who can survive or I'm
the only one that can have this
um like overcome my mental health issues
and you know I want everyone to be able
to do what I've done and basically
um yeah so
um I I that's why I try and
pass it on to other people and pass it
on to my patients as well that's a
lovely answer and you say that you're
not a special case but I think you do
really come across as a special person I
think you're someone that we've met
previously and you're someone that we've
talked about a lot uh you come across as
very strong very articulate and
um
I'm really grateful to you to come and
talk to us today about a topic that's
really
hard to talk about but I can tell that
the reason you want to do it is because
you want to create positive change yeah
so
thank you for your time oh um yeah
you're welcome you're welcome um it's a
um it's a pleasure to be here because
um I really want
um to
for you know I I hope from these
interviews
um with with a loud Bible that I can
actually reach more
um victims and survivors and let them
know that
um there's someone out there who
understands you and there's someone out
there in a position to help who is
trying to help
um and um they don't have to be the ones
to come forward and talk about it I'll
talk about it I'll talk about the
horrible things that happened to me
embarrass myself but not embarrass
myself
um so that other people don't feel that
they have to come forward unless they
feel comfortable too
um yeah
um it's not for the trolls
she'll give us a little I think that's
yeah
I looked to the side of the Qatar and
she had a jar
with things in it clitoris Libya model
everything that she has cut previously I
looked at it and I thought I'm gonna die
and then being sewn the one experience
that I don't think I will ever forget